Hello Freak bitches.
See I'm weird about it.
I even,
I like,
I like wheat,
but I think alcohol,
I love fucking when I'm on alcohol inhibition thing,
but a lot of people don't like the alcohol,
you know,
people are saying,
oh,
I can get,
you know,
whiskey Dick or something.
If you get really fucked up you can get whiskey deck.
But yeah,
you'd have to drink a lot.
Yeah,
I would not.
I would have to be not alive.
Of course you're limited.
Got,
have a glass of wine.
I've gotten whiskers creek before for sure.
Real fuck.
Yeah,
for sure.
I think I have ever been done that too.
If you start the problem when you start drinking,
his alcohol reduces inhibitions,
right?
It removes your inhibitions and it removes your inhibitions more with every
drink.
So you know,
if you're,
if you're a little,
you know,
little tipsy,
you got like a little bit of inhibition or throw up on a check.
No,
right.
As I was about to eat her pussy
hot chick,
I was 19.
I was like,
we were drinking greyhounds.
I'll never forget it was the greyhound.
Greyhound is a,
I think it's Jen.
It's grey hound.
It's,
it's light green,
light yellow.
I'm not sure what the alcohol bunch of blueberries.
It's great fruit juice and vodka or something like that.
I think it's great.
The juice and vodka.
Anyways,
it was a grey hound.
Whatever the fuck it is.
I'm not a bartender.
So mad.
I couldn't believe I was getting this piece.
Ash Super Hot,
open up the legs and right.
All I remember is
I threw up,
grabbed me.
She grabbed me and dragged me down the hallway and I just remember seeing the,
going through the hallway,
throwing up down the hallway,
trying to get me to the toilet.
And I finally get to the toilet.
I have a couple more.
Uh,
jakks left.
He's never had.
Never fucked her.
I never saw her again.
Never saw them when I was.
There's no way you can come back from that.
You can fuck up the throw up into her.
When I was young and I
use a lube on her ass when I was prime carrot in there.
Why take the carrot out fucker?
It has.
Enzymes are retarded.
I think you get burned yourself.
Probably burn your stomach in your penis hole,
sir.
What do you have?
Bile Burns on your Dick.
Whatever.
Man.
Who loves it,
man.
Nobody ain't throw it up on your Dick.
Tried to
blow up.
You threw up in her and then just said it's all slippery down now.
Let me just start.
That might be good gallery and shit.
It might be really good.
It was over.
I fell asleep.
I was going down on my girlfriend once.
At least once to have my paper route.
Yeah,
that's quite common,
but I didn't fall asleep because I was tired because I fucking threw papers all
day.
I got tired.
I'd be like drunk and partied all night.
You just get home,
right?
He pull down your pants and you just fall asleep or something.
She goes to the bathroom and you're just waiting and you're done.
She comes back and you're snoring.